and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists Ryan today we're gonna talk
about decluttering nice are we gonna go
over the eight easy steps to
decluttering your closet
there's sixty-seven actually oh okay
I've been keeping a list checking it
twice we've got so many questions that
we actually reached out to a bunch of
folks on patreon thank you to all of our
patreon supporters for keeping the show
100% advertisement free sales are
awesome I tell you what let's just dive
right in these questions the first
question is from Janine wood she says
when it comes to hobbies and their
accoutrements what's the best way to
know what to keep and what to get rid of
even if you think you're going to use it
again sometime they can pile up for sure
man yeah I mean it's funny writing a
chapter in it for our new book it's
called love people use things available
nowhere where books are sold
because it's still being written but
there's a chapter in there about stuff
you know the obviously the for those of
you who have listened to us before you
know that we have these different
relationships in our lives this book is
sort of the relationship book but not
need traditional sense it's our
relationship with the truth our
relationship with our values our
relationship with our relation finances
yeah yeah people finances money but also
our relationship with our stuff and
we've created a strange relationship
with stuff in this sort of
post-industrial world and especially
with the sort of post 1970s post 1980
world of the ubiquity of free and cheap
products I say free and cheap because
there's a lot of things that are way
less expensive and easy to access but
there's also we're just given a ton of
free things remember when we were in the
corporate world Ryan and we would go to
like conventions or events and they'd
just hand out tchotchkes and beer hands
these number customer appreciation day
yes oh my god ma'am he will be people
would be fighting over tote bags and
like do you really need a tote bag but
because it's free I'd be stupid not to
take it a riot free pen
and all of these things that we don't
actually want but we tell ourselves that
we do want these things and so when I'm
looking at a
Janine's question here man I'm thinking
about some of the rules that I've been
writing about you and I have over the
last decades since simplifying we've
sort of created some rules in our life
now there isn't a minimalist rulebook I
wish there was
here are the 17 rules to follow and
you'll be the the perfect minimalist
yeah yeah we can only talk to what works
for us right but what you know what
other what has worked for other people
but yeah ultimately these are just
thoughts and ideas for people to take
and what I like about our rules too is
they're totally malleable yes they are
you know you think about the 9090 rule
where you know if you haven't used in
the last 90 days
or if you don't plan on using it in the
next 90 days that works great for you
and me
what works great for most of my stuff
there are some seasonal things which
we'll get to actually in the question so
yeah I listen work for but but it
doesn't have to be 90 90 for you at home
or in your car or wherever you listen to
this podcast it can be it could be 91 91
right and and I think that's the thing
when we're talking about rules these are
rules that have worked well for us
they're almost policies in a way
sometimes you can you can break a policy
when it makes sense to rules that came
to mind for me one is the just-in-case
rule yeah and probably my favorite rule
yeah it's the first one we came up with
- it is we it was 2011 we were on tour
and we were trying to not pack as much
stuff and we realized we were packing so
many things just in case we needed it in
some hypothetical future yeah I open up
the trunk and I saw all your luggage and
I said Josh you're a hypocrite yeah me
too and so what I realized is that when
we got home from tour like oh this also
applies to my physical goods at home I'm
holding on even as a so-called
minimalist and I'm still holding on to
this and that and this and these jeans
and this t-shirt I haven't worn it in a
year but you know what up there hold on
to it just in case I might need it
someday in some far-off non-existent
hypothetical future and that that
justification made me hoard a bunch of
things that I
didn't actually get value from
whatsoever what were your biggest
culprits my more t-shirts every time I
had a free t-shirt I'm like oh I'd be
stupid not to take this t-shirt I can
wear this for the next time I paint but
then I ended up with like 30 painting
t-shirts every week and you're like
finding something to paint you change
your shirt every hour yeah or like
yardwork shirts I mean which makes sense
by the way aren't painting shirts and
your artwork sure it's the same thing
exactly although you had enough that you
could have a drawer of yardwork shirts
and a drawer of painting shirts and
still not wear them all yeah yeah for me
it was cosmetics mostly from the makeup
no that's a real problem though with
with some some folks yeah for sure III
remember when I was the own mum stuff
you know when when after she passed like
she had makeup I swear to you that was
from the 1980s like she was holding onto
so many things just in case it looked
like someone was trying to start a
beauty supply business in her bathroom
and it was moisturizer and concealer and
makeup and some of them still were like
sealed or in packages that had been
there for probably months or years that
were never used because what we do is we
we fall victim we're susceptible to
you're walking to CVS and you're like oh
look at that Maybelline model it's buy
one get one free right I'd be dumb not
to buy two then I didn't even want to
buy one but now I'm gonna buy two
because it's 100 percent off that second
one but of course it's a hundred percent
off if you don't buy anything at all
when you when you walk out of the store
so for me the the just in case rule so
let's break that down real quick we also
call its aka the 20/20 rule right
anything that I'm holding on to just in
case I can get rid of for let or I can
get rid of because I can replace it for
less than twenty dollars in less than 20
minutes from wherever I am but Josh
think of all that money you're gonna be
wasting that would be true and that
would actually worry me if that were
true yeah because it's hopefully you're
getting rid of things that you're not
using right so there's no need to
replace it
right and now that rule has worked for
us 100% of the time and I think I've
only had to use it about a handful of
times over the course of the last decade
now think about that let's say I've had
to use it five times in the last decade
so it's cost me less than $100 let's
just call it $100 over the last 10 years
right would you spend $100 to get rid of
all of your clutter that is just in case
clutter right yeah of course I would and
so yes I've had to use it a couple times
once I used it for a pair of scissors
once was for a pair of shorts that I can
remember I don't even remember the other
time yeah I did a really toothbrush five
but think about it man some people are
actually paying about a hundred bucks a
month or even more to hold on right so
they're just in case stuff in his
storage I'd know I had a storage shed
for a little bit and it was all of these
like whoa
maybe one day I'll start to use these
things again right and so what it does
by spending that hundred dollars over
the course of a decade it gives you
permission to let go of the literally
tens of thousands of just-in-case items
that the average American household is
holding on to now there is a close
correlate rule to the just-in-case rule
and it's called the just for win rule
and we often get confused and we say
well hold on to this just in case so
what about when I actually do need the
thing well there are some things we hold
on to just for when we know we're
absolutely going to you or even like
like hopefully like for example a first
aid kit I hope that isn't adjust for one
well I'm going to talk about that in a
second this is a just-in-case item that
I can justify okay let's talk about
there are some just in case items that I
hold on to and I will make it up in the
rules
okay just where are you going with it
just for win rule are things like I
obviously don't go to the store and buy
one Kleenex at a time I'm gonna buy an
entire box of Kleenex even though I
might not use them all I'm so glad I can
buy an entire box of Kleenex No right
because I know I'm going to use it at
some point in the near future it is a
just for win item the same is true with
toilet paper we don't buy our toilet
paper one square at a time right we
don't buy paper towels one paper towel
sheet at a time or select the size there
are certain things to yeah literally
coffee filters for example like if I get
five packages of coffee filters and I
can get them you know
whatever like I know I'm gonna use
coffee filters like that is a given and
I like to have enough they're just like
what toilet paper paper towels it's like
I don't want to run out and then have to
run to the store when I need more so
usually when I get down like one or two
packs of coffee filters I'll go by you
know five more plus you buy that you're
buying it in bulk that makes sense for a
few reasons one is it lowers your
shipping costs or also the B cost on the
environment if you're having them
shipped to you you don't want to have a
good point one square of toilet paper or
one coffee filter or even one package of
coffee filters shipped to you but also
you have to consider do I have the space
for this I'm with you when I buy coffee
filters I'll buy seven or eight packs at
once because I have enough room in my
little coffee cabinet for eight packs of
coffee filters so I have enough space
now if I were to buy 50 packs yes I'm
gonna use these eventually but I don't
actually have the space for it I'd have
to like put it in Ella's sock drawer or
something
yeah and so that that doesn't make as
much sense so we have the just in case
for the just for win rule understand
that some things we're holding on to
where you hold on to adjust rowing
because we're certain we're going to use
it we know that it will get used and
then there are some just in case items
that it might be appropriate if it are
appropriate because you can't replace
them for less than twenty dollars in
less than twenty minutes and and I think
the emergency kit that you just
mentioned yeah is the best example of
that
yeah dude if you're living in Montana I
mean you should have a blanket in the
back here car what do they what do they
tell you it's like a blanket some water
and a pound of roast beef canned roast
beef pound of roast beast I wouldn't
stay fresh Josh but no seriously like
you should have something driving around
in the wintertime there I mean if you
get stuck in the middle of nowhere
you're right like it can't be replaced
in less than 20 minutes for less than
$20 and your life might depend on it
right so certainly there are some
exceptions to the rule there are
emergency just in case items that often
make sense however we have to be careful
with that too because we can justify
just about anything and so we have to we
have to really look ourselves in the
mirror and be honest with ourselves is
this something that I truly need in case
of emergency if if so in case of
emergency
is a just-in-case item yeah but it's
okay to have some emergency items to
plan for emergencies yeah
that said even when you plan for
emergencies you can't plan for every
emergent it's absolutely true and I just
want to point out too like Josh and I we
can't make this decision for you like
this is for you like you said Josh it's
for them to look in the mirror and be
honest with themselves because yes you
could go down the slippery slope and
hang on to all these just in case items
and then and then you're just gonna be
right back to a cluttered closet or
whatever so Janine when it comes to your
hobbies let me talk about my hobbies a
little bit so I snowboard I'm mountain
bike I scuba dive and I guess when it
comes to my hobbies I think about what
do I have room for what can I afford
financially what what is going to be the
best use of the space that I have now
Mariah and I we just moved into a new
apartment yesterday it is a studio
apartment
it's although it has two bathrooms which
is really strange I feel like they could
have like extended the bedroom or
something but anyway we have a smart way
of a smaller amount of space so like
Mariah and I right now are kind of going
through this or what are we gonna do
with our bikes what are we going to do
with our snowboards and I think we're
gonna have enough room to fit everything
in there we're still unpacking right now
but you know ultimately if I've got to
go buy a storage shed to put something
in I'm going to really ask myself
whether or not I want to continue doing
that hobby and the other thing too is
there are a lot of hobbies I want to
pick up and I would love to start
fly-fishing I would love to but you know
what comes along with fly-fishing all
the fly fishing gear and I don't have
room for that right now did you just do
spearfishing instead all you needs a
spear do genius down order me a spear
off of Amazon but you need sort of
length of that spear in the show notes
so so Janine that's that's what I'm
gonna recommend is when it comes to
hobbies specifically is you know what is
it that you can afford in your life and
you know when it comes to slick
snowboarding I only do that a couple
months out of the year in fact living in
Los Angeles I'm not doing it nearly as
much as when I lived in Montana so I
might go snowboarding
you know when I was in Montana I was
going a dozen you know maybe a dozen and
a half times a year and now I might go a
half a dozen times so I still love
snowboarding I'm going to snowboard I
know I'm going to use it and I know I
can afford it not just the financial
cost but the cost of up keeping the
thing cleaning the thing and storing the
thing and all of all of that so Janine
when it comes to your hobbies ask what
it is that you can afford and be honest
with yourself if you actually are going
to to do those hobbies if you haven't
done like if I haven't done a hobby in a
year I will seriously question whether
or not I'm going to keep all the
equipment that comes along with that a
great example is golf I love golf I suck
at it so bad and I feel like most people
when they practice they get better but
for some reason when I practice I get
worse but when I moved to Montana I had
this beautiful set of golf clubs I think
you know the the monetary cost when I
first got them I bought them when I was
in the corporate world there for like
800 bucks I mean it was like a nice bag
nice set of golf clubs and for that
first year I did not golf when we were
in Montana the second year I'm like
alright I need to get rid of so go
golfing I went golfing and again I got
worse than when I had done previously
and I was like you know what I'm not I
don't have the time to snowboard to
mountain bike to hike to longboard to
you know whatever whatever sports that I
have in my life and also to get good at
golf so I found someone who it's
actually Mariah's ex-roommate he does
golf a lot he is a good golfer and I
gave him this beautiful set of golf
clubs and I'll tell you what the joy
that he got from those golf clubs it
actually made me feel a lot better about
getting about getting rid of it but
there's just an example for you when you
aren't doing a hobby that you think that
you actually love I mean I guess you got
a got to look in the mirror and ask
yourself do you really love it uh you
know I think I think you brought up a
good point there and it's a new rule to
consider is if you haven't done a hobby
within a year then it's probably not a
hobby of yours anymore yeah
all right let's say uh Janine real quick
I love this in your copy of one of our
books Ryan and I have written three
books together we in this order
minimalism everything that remains and
then essential the book I want to send
you is a book called essential it's an
essay collection 100
50 different essays about 12 different
areas of life that are the intentional
era intentional living areas and in that
book we talk about one of the chapters
one of those twelve areas is stuff it's
sort of our how-to book if you go
through our books you have everything
that remains which is the y2 book you
have minimalism which is the what to
book it talks about our values and then
you have essential which is the how-to
book and I think Jeanine you'll find a
lot of value in that if you like our
podcast you'll like Abby who I almost
would love but you probably won't love
it it's just a book it's not a person
you know there are like seven different
meanings for love right yeah in the
English language it becomes a problem
and you know we often talk about this
and it's one of the things I'm writing
about in in the book is we want to be
careful not to love our things because I
think it really waters down the love
that we have for the people closest to
us so I hope you enjoy there's a better
word for you hope you enjoy the copy of
essential if you want the audiobook
we'll send you that or if you want the
book book or the e-book we'll be happy
to send that to you Ryan once you move
onto crystals question all right crystal
wrote in how or I'm sorry she wrote in
what should I keep and what should I
toss when it comes to seasonal or
special occasion clothes and shoes yes
so what are seasons we live in Los
Angeles and just one season here so
that's your answer you just moved to
California be fine you can get rid of
all the other three seasons were things
we have something called the seasonal
rule it's also known as the 9090 rule
ryan alluded to it earlier but I'll just
go through it really quickly because
we're getting shorter and shorter on
time here the 9090 rule covers most
seasons so we're recording this right
now in September right and so if I look
90 days so it's fall right now
early fall and if I look 90 days back
that goes into and fall by the way is
this roughly the same thing as spring
right I mean seasonal seasonally if
you're living in a place with with all
four seasons spring and fall are pretty
similar when they're wives right and so
so right now we're in fall which also
covers spring but if you look back 90
days then we're in
the summer so have I used this in the
last 90 days and then am I going to use
it in the next 90 days well that's gonna
cover winter for us so that effectively
covers every season the 90 90 rule and
for me I even tried to take a little bit
more extreme all often look at things
they have I use this in the last 30 days
and if not am I going to use it in the
next 30 before I even extend out to the
90 90 rule but I know that rule is
really helpful for folks because it
makes you realize like wow I bought that
sweatshirt thinking I was going to wear
it last winter and I never did and if
I'm being honest with myself it was an
aspirational purchase and I'm probably
not going to wear it this winter either
yeah so I haven't used the last 90 I'm
not gonna use in the next 90 then I give
myself permission to let go yeah no I
think it's I think it's a great point
man I mean just come up with your own
rules on what is appropriate for your
life
I mean crystal we can't sit here and be
like well you need you need some special
occasion clothes for weddings and for
funerals and for X Y & Z I mean what is
appropriate for your life what's really
gonna help you hold on to the
appropriate amount of things is being
clear with what is appropriate for your
life and you'll probably hear Josh and I
say that a lot well here's the word
appropriate I think that the the 9090
rule also helps me use some of the
things that I wouldn't otherwise use
within 90 days yeah so you just
mentioned like having a seasonal or a
special occasion sort of clothing I own
a suit and I don't have occasions to
wear that suit generally every 90 day
I'm just imagining you like after 90
days of not using it you just like put
it on and sit around your house and
usually sort of actually what I'll do is
when Beck's is coming in from the
airport I will put a suit on and pick
her up because she just loves the way I
look in a suit that's great and so it
gives me a an excuse to wear the suit
make her like feel good about it and I
put my suit on my tie my dress shoes and
I actually yeah you feel different doing
that now I used to wear a shirt and tie
every day a suit every day you know and
so you you quickly get used to not
having to
err that noose around your neck and it
feels really strange I mean I used to
have it every single syllable so I have
I got one shirt with a collar on it
because every once in a while Mariah and
I will go to a you know restaurant where
they're like you have to have a collared
shirt so like I have it just for one
yeah I don't own a suit because I love
not having that noose around my neck so
even though weddings and funerals like I
will like what I'm wearing right now
this is what I wear doing headaches and
funerals and no one's ever given me any
guff for it proposal you aren't watching
on YouTube Brian is naked yes yes
exactly oh I have a loincloth on all
right we got a question here from guy
Whitlock guy says I recently became one
of your 1,000 true fans on patreon woo
nice thanks guy guy you're one of the
only people who actually matter to us
it's him you and me who have joined the
true fans here so so we have this tear
where there's a thousand true fans it's
based on Kevin Kelly's theory about
having a thousand true fans we actually
recently capped our patreon supporter
roughly at four thousand now we're just
trying to keep it relatively private
over there on the private podcast that's
why but there's there's two different
tiers there there's the sort of private
podcast patrons but then there's a
higher tier with the true fans where you
also get access to all of our live event
I can't wait to hit 4,000 patrons that's
happiness it's right around the corner
action by the time this comes out we
might be at four thousand already we've
got a goal up there that Sean Jess and
Jordan are going to do a podcast
together and divulge all of our secret
things we get the four thousand anyway
guys says you guys are fantabulous well
thank you guy anyway here's my question
you know the saying a place for
everything and everything in its place
well I'm a stickler about this it really
keeps me sane and relaxed however my
wife and eight-year-old daughter just
can't seem to get the hang of it and it
makes so much more work for me around
the house and in the car help alright
guy when they're gone I want to throw
away all their stuff just joking I do
need to point out one thing he had the
longest question of the day and it
wasn't actually a question he said
here's my question and then he just went
on a rant for a moment and
hey here's the problem I have it's my
daughter and my wife there's a question
mark in that sentence somewhere no there
literally isn't no I'm joking there is
in that in this in that third sentence
but but yeah I mean yeah alternately guy
thank you for the statement so here's
what I'll say to you guy maybe you're
creating some unnecessary unnecessarily
restrictive rules and I'm only saying
that because I know that I have done it
repeatedly where there are 15 things
that need to happen in order for me to
be let me use your exact words here sane
and relaxed mmm in order for me to be
sane and relax all the laundry needs to
be folded it needs to be done the dishes
need to be done the floor needs to be
sweep and mop tanned vacuumed the bed
needs to be made Ella's bed needs to be
made oh wait we didn't make the bed
right let me redo that really quickly oh
and you know what the cabinet's they're
they I like to have all the products
especially the cleaning products neat
and orderly like you would see on a OCD
store shelf and so it has to be exactly
like that before I can be sane and
relaxed and you know what yeah that is
probably optimal for me but the
opportunity cost of having a family is
clutter and you're gonna have some
clutter sometimes some things that that
you may have to to compromise right and
and so I think the best thing that I
could recommend for you is something
that I've done with my own family and
it's creating new expectations together
yeah and and what I mean by that is
don't set expectations you want to talk
at your wife and at your kid and here's
what you need to do in order for me to
be saying and relaxed know what we need
to do is say hey you know what would
really help me XY and Z would really
help me and then by the way to five most
powerful words for me or would you be
willing to would you be willing to help
me with this because if they care about
you which we know your family does then
they would be willing to help you but
then also you need to give some you need
to give a little bit would you be
willing to let go of the some of the
expectations that you've created and if
so I think you'll be in a better place
because of a guy yeah I think dude
Mariah now we do a great job of going
our way to show each other that we love
each other every single day as much as
we can and I'll do things that I
normally wouldn't do if I live by myself
but because mariah has well you know
years ago when we first started living
together she's like hey Ryan would you
mind doing X Y & Z that would really
help me out and one thing is is like I
will leave my boxers in the bathroom
my sketti hat but no I I mean that's
what I did when I when I lived by myself
and I would you know I'd leave him there
in the morning and I pick him up later
it sound like I just had a big pile of
boxes in the bathroom but like it wasn't
an immediate thing for me to grab them
and put them in the dirty clothes more I
was like hey do you mind do that I'm
like yeah I would love to do that so if
you go out of your way guy to do things
that your wife and your daughter really
appreciate you doing I promise you guy
that they are gonna go out of their way
to do things for you so that I think
that's the biggest part of of this whole
set of this whole equation is is you've
got to support your wife and daughter as
much as possible with things that you
know that they like maybe even that you
necessarily don't agree with them or
like what what they're you know what you
have to do for them but if you show them
support they will show you support back
Julien has a question here Julien says
what would you recommend for storing
holiday decorations they only come out
certain times of the year and our store
in storage the rest of the year and they
just take up space I guess my question
would my question back to her would be
what what holidays right you you don't
have decorations for every holiday you
you figured out holidays that you want
decorations for did did you just take
down your Labor Day decorations or what
about your Flag Day decorations this
past June right and so there are certain
holidays that we don't ever put up
decorations for there are other holidays
that we've told ourselves a story like I
need to have decorations for this and
then of course I need to then take the
decorations down for I have a friend who
leaves holiday decorations up the
Christmas holiday decorations up all a
year what if you were to do that by the
way the city of Beverly Hills does that
if
drive through Beverly Hills like down La
Cienega they have the lights on the palm
trees all the Christmas lights on the
palm trees all year round and it creates
a sort of feeling of you know the same
feeling you might get the holiday cheer
our friend TK Coleman listens to
Christmas music every day of the year he
doesn't wait until Christmas so you can
leave some of these decorations out what
what would happen if you left them out
and then if there are holidays that you
no longer want decorations for like Flag
Day then don't do it
I got rid all my Flag Day decorations oh
man all right Katie she writes in what
do you recommend and feel is reasonable
for children's toys our three-year-old
is strengthening his giving muscle but
it's hard for him to let go I have some
news for you Katie well two things
number one is the appropriate item
number is 1212 toys if you are a kid
it's actually I am joking but there is a
stat that the average Western child has
300 toys but plays with twelve daily and
so that is an actual stat that really
illustrate doesn't mean that twelves
magical number it just means that on
average that's what kids play with and
we have an abundance of toys you've of
course heard of the paradox of choice
the paradox of choice means you walk in
your room you have 300 toys I've seen
this with kids where they just panic and
they're like they're I don't have
anything to play with but if they have
three things to play with they're like
okay well good better best or one two
three let me pick let me pick one and
then they start playing with it but if
they're overwhelmed then it becomes
harder but that's true with me and you
as well I have news for you Katie if
it's hard for your three-year-old to let
go that might be true but it's also
really hard for us as adults to let go
right and so that behavior doesn't go
away once you get older yeah maybe it
becomes a little bit easier as you get
some traction there is this analytical
philosopher his name is Bernardo Kastrup
and he is this this great quote I'm
probably gonna butcher it here the prime
directive of the mind is self-deception
mm-hmm
and all he's really saying is we love to
trick ourselves thinking we need 300
toys when we're a kid or 300 thousand
items when we're an adult the bigger
house the bigger car it's all about the
stories that we tell ourselves and so
the antidote then is what we have to
tell ourselves some new stories and that
new story might be that hey this toy
isn't serving a purpose anymore let's
find it a new home or that new story
might be I get a lot of value from
having this set of toys these toys are
in the way as opposed to I also have
these toys yeah
Katie kids love to create I mean give
them see how many toys how few toys you
can get away with and watch your kids
have fun I remember when I was like in
the second grade my grandfather sent my
mom in check for like a hundred bucks or
something and he was like take Ryan to
the toy store and get him whatever he
wants we went to Toys R Us when it was
still around although I think it's
making a comeback I heard in the news
column is we went to Toys R Us in dude
I'm telling you like I could I couldn't
choose anything I was so overwhelmed
with the paradox of choice you know what
I ended up getting what Legos and I'm
getting Legos and like it was my
favorite toy because I could create with
them right because you got an infinite
number of toys effectively yeah with
that box of Legos yeah I'm thinking of
our friend Rob Bell he has this great
video about like his I think this is yes
son
one of his two sons they went dad and
son day going to the toy store I said
son you can get whatever you want and
he's he runs around the store and he
comes back with this little blue shovel
he's like no no you can get anything in
the store that you want he's like yeah I
want the blue shovel because that means
you and I can play in the backyard
hours and it's a $1 plastic blue shovel
yeah but what was meaningful wasn't the
shovel what was the experience that he
was having alright looks like we got a
bunch more questions to answer we got a
question here about tradition we have a
question about organization tips for
someone who can't seem to declutter in
their small apartment we have a question
about decluttering our mobile phone home
screens we have a question about
decluttering boxes and boxes and boxes
of photographs we have a question about
the why behind decluttering not just the
how to but the why to we're gonna talk
about that we also have a question about
how do you declutter gifts without
hurting the gift givers feelings we're
gonna talk about getting rid of our
adult children's favorite toys that
we're still hoarding in our basement we
have a question my parents always want
to salvage things I want to get rid of
what should I do
also how to declutter when you don't
have a lot of space in your house Ryan
this will be fascinating with you
because you you just moved into a 100
square foot apartment yeah pretty much
the studio apartment also uh we're gonna
talk about the monetary value of things
we're gonna talk about decluttering your
social circles online and unfriending
people we're gonna talk about what the
insides of our cars look like and you'll
be surprised at Ryan's and my cars are
actually appreciably different on the
interior and then we're gonna talk about
that and got a lot more to talk about if
you want to hear all that you can listen
to this week's maximal episode available
exclusively on patreon that's right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different much longer
maximal episode on the minimalist
private podcast which gives us the
private space we need to talk about
topics we don't usually discuss in
public plus patreon is the best way for
us to fund this podcast to keep it 100%
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the middle most private podcast on
patreon you'll receive a personal link
so that our maximal episodes play in
your favorite podcast app you find all
the details and all the good stuff over
at the minimalists com a slash support
Ryan what else you got for us this week
being informed as more in
than ever these days so I encourage all
of our listeners and our viewers to read
more and get informed and also I've got
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners check them out hi my name
is Karen and I'm calling from
Philadelphia I'm calling in response to
the impulses episode and I had a comment
for Erica who has the business that may
or may not align with her minimalist
values now I just had a thought about
that because I so and I do a lot of
sewing for a living so I've always had a
large stash of fabrics I also have a
side retail business that buzzes me to
sell things to people and I don't always
feel comfortable about their purchases
it sounds like her business is some sort
of a craft or yarn store and I thought
it might be a good way to at least
partially transition to start doing
events either at the store or at another
location put up a sign to our customers
hey is your yarn stash getting
overwhelming come join me and your other
customers and knit for a good cause make
something for the homeless make things
to donate to refugees do something that
will use up some of that stash make
people feel good about what they're
doing with it and also get together as a
community it might be a way to spread
some minimalist values while she's
hosting but it would also do a lot of
good in the short and long term hi my
name is Cody from Hawaii Nevada I'm
responding to episode 46 called let go
you were talking about social media and
particularly scrolling through Facebook
how it how it brings discontent and is
essentially a waste of time my solution
to that is that I have unfollowed all of
my quote friends and groups this makes
my newsfeed completely empty and clean
and keeps me from scrolling mindlessly
to see what people are up to some people
might think of this as being a bit
extreme but I find that it allows me to
be more deliberate in my use of Facebook
if I'm thinking about someone in
particular I can go directly to their
profile and
see what they're up to or I can send
them a message and actually talk with
them another thing I do to minimize
Facebook is that I try to keep my
friends list below 150 people studies
have shown that the human mind cannot
keep track of more than 150
relationships if you have more than 150
chances are there are people on your
list that you don't know or remember
either way they are probably not adding
value to your life and are not worth
cluttering up your social media all
right show real quick four right here
right now here's one thing that is going
on in the life of the minimalist
actually two things Ryan one is we have
a side project called minimalism life
folks want to check that out they can at
wwm in embolism dot life and there is a
bunch of free stuff they're free
wallpapers free journal articles all
kinds of writings about minimalism and
simplicity and simple living and
architecture and design and travel all
things minimalist over there there's
also a subscription side called inside
minimalism and I'm going to be
publishing some snippets from love
people use things over there exclusively
so it won't be available to the public
at all but if you want to get involved
with that and check out some snippets
from our book that comes out in 2021
then that's the only place you'll be
able to find it over at inside
minimalism
minimalism dot life you know I used to
always be really angry because there was
a better-looking minimalist website than
ours minimalism oh yeah and well right
so so you know long story short you know
if you can't beat them join them
right now we're part of we're part of
this project and I'm so happy because
yet is such a beautiful beautiful
website you talk about just beautiful
aesthetics yeah Alberto from five style
and Carl from minimalism oh like they
just have an eye for aesthetics and
we're actually gonna be talking about
aesthetics during during the patreon
episode as well because it's something
that's important it's not the most
important thing but it is certainly part
of the recipe you want to put your best
foot forward and we've certainly done
that with minimalism dot life you can
check that out also my wife is doing the
healthy and whole project
over at minimal wellness.com she is
doing this nine week course right now
that starts October 1st so if you're
interested in that and she's a
registered dietitian also a paragon of
Health one of the healthiest people I
have ever met in my life and she's
helped a lot of people she spent a
decade at a university helping a lot of
students with eating disorders but also
folks who just want to better manage
their their diet and figure out their
dietary restrictions figure out how to
optimize their health she's doing a 9
week course all around that and you can
find that over at minimal wellness comm
that is her website where she posts a
lot of really great recipes and a bunch
of other free stuff as well all right if
you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast leave us
voicemail four zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine or send a voice
memo to podcast at the minimalists comm
you can comment on this episode
youtube.com / the minimus if you want
our show notes in your inbox sign up for
our email list over at the minimalists
comm you'll also receive our simple
Sunday emails and for our added value
this week Ryan I wanted to play a song
and I was trying to figure out what what
song I should play before we started
this there was a great song from Joell
Ortiz his new album called Monday just
came out it's called screens but I think
I want to save that for we're gonna
ready to do a podcast episode with Chris
Ryan and he has a book coming out called
civilized to death and screens is sort
of a lament on how we've grown up
without screens but now all kids are
forced to to listen to screen or toe to
just watch screens all day and they're
tantalized by them but you know what we
might as well play it now since I've
teased it enough wasn't two screens by
Joell Ortiz from his new album Monday
and if you leave here today with just
one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus